[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja das wird er an weihnachten ist dieses
jahr extrem wir erwarten eher
frühlingswetter als dass wir jetzt
weihnachtswetter erwarten
wir sind hier beim deutschen
wetterdienst als nationale behörde als
der nationale wetterdienst deutschland
sind wir zuständig für alle
wettervorhersagen vor allem für die
warnungen das heißt hier von offenbach
werden und bei der warnung herausgeben
für ganz deutschland
woran liegt es dass es dieses jahr
wieder keine waisen weihnachten gibt man
kann sagen es liegt an der
großwetterlage
das ist nämlich immer für uns
entscheidend großwetterlage bedeutet
dass wir hier jetzt ein tiefdruckgebiet
haben was über den britischen inseln
liegt und hohem luftdruck über see im
südosten europas
und da muss man wissen dass auf der
nordhalbkugel die luft sich gegen den
uhrzeigersinn dreht um einen
tiefdruckgebiet und das bedeutet bei
dieser großwetterlage dass die luft aus
südwesteuropa nach deutschland gerichtet
ist und damit kommt sehr warme und
feuchte luft nach deutschland und
deshalb grüne weihnacht
[Musik]
ich denke man kann jetzt nicht sagen
dass unsere kinder und enkelkinder
niederschlesien an weihnachten das kann
immer mal wieder extreme ausschläge
geben nur sie werden seltener dh das ist
wirklich klappt und dass man noch mal
schnee und frost hat an weihnachten das
wird eigentlich immer unwahrscheinlicher
und das ist der trend der hier durch den
klimawandel
[Musik]
wir haben mal die daten sogar bis 1950
ausgewertet und da kam raus dass hier so
für das rhein-main-gebiet etwa alle zehn
jahre es nur zu weißen weihnachten kam
und auch momentan kommt weiße
weihnachten heißt das wirklich an den
drei feiertagen dann 24 25 und 26
dezember ein zentimeter schnee liegt und
das passiert hier wirklich sehr selten
zehn prozent der fälle im moment kann
man noch nicht sagen dass es schon
deutlich abgenommen hat durch den
klimawandel
aber wenn man davon ausgeht dass unser
klima sich weiter erfahren die nächsten
jahrzehnte
dann muss man auch davon ausgehen dass
dann weiße weihnachten noch geringer
wird von der wahrscheinlichkeit also ich
würde mal sagen in 30 jahren wenn man
von den zehn prozent sehr deutlich nach
unten gehen und dann vielleicht nur noch
alle 20 jahre mein gebet malweise
weihnachten erleben
[Musik]
[Applaus]